il reste encore attirer les joints et
resterai le plafond suspendu à mettre si
des travaux inachevés pour denis
brossard dix mois après le bris de la
digue à sainte-marthe-sur-le-lac ce qui
marche pas c'est que dans les montants
2e et les montants de moi on n'est pas
pas d'autres sur la même longueur d'onde
denis brossard a pourtant reçu une
lettre du ministère de la sécurité
publique
mentionnons le paiement final son
dossier allait être fermé j'ai fourni la
facture de la diminution de la dalle
j'ai fourni la facture due pour les
fissures et la sai merlon pas payer
encore lober un disque un monde aussi
fait que notre graphe l'île sont leurs
gardes des manques vite 9000 $ à peu
près en date du 17 février le ministère
de la sécurité publique a traité 1461
dossiers de particuliers dont 92%
d'entre eux sont complétés fait sauter
les pièces qu'on avait noté des jo
isabelle gervais a ouvert son dossier le
10 mai dernier elle a rencontré son
agent il y a deux semaines à peine les
fouilles dans son dossier taki qui sort
un plein qui se pose est que le dessin
notre sous-sol 9,6 ce pas notre maison
tout comme d'autres sinistrés dont le
dossier est passé entre les mains de
plusieurs agents elle déplore le
cafouillage mais ils sont où ces
informations la langue aussi nous on
tour demandé le croquis des photos ce
sol des pièces trop isabelle gervais
crois que le ministère a bien hâte de
tourner la page j'ai dit non non non je
vais pas perdre ma finale non c'est
parce qu'à peindre dans mon dossier on
le sent la ion de la pression ça va
faire un an bientôt malgré les délais
les sinistrés veulent être traités avec
empathie vous fasse antique on est des
humains et on est on est des gens qui
ont été blessés une blessure encore vive
malgré le temps qui passe
c'est ce que avril mai juin la dre
d'alien marché là il ya pas mal moins
des deux nèthes d'adrénaline des chefs
on redescend l'ul la force de vouloir
continuer et puis je mets ici marie
josée pas quelques moues radio canada
montréal